ah
i
con el puño arriba y su rodilla al suelo
la gimnasta costarricense luciana
alvarado demostró su apoyo a black lives
matters la joven de 18 años realizó este
gesto como parte de su rutina de suelo
encontrando una forma de evadir la regla
del comité olímpico que prohíbe
cualquier demostración política
religiosa o racial en las instalaciones
donde se realizan los juegos los medios
lo reportan como un gesto histórico es
el primero de este tipo en un escenario
internacional en gimnasia élite black
lights matters tomó fuerza en eeuu y en
el mundo tras el asesinato de george
floyd a manos de un policía un hecho que
causó conmoción y protestas contra la
brutalidad policial y el racismo
sistémico luciana dijo que ella y su
prima han incorporado este gesto como
parte de sus coreografías es importante
que todos sean tratados con respeto y
dignidad y todos deben tener los mismos
derechos porque somos iguales dijo la
primera gimnasta costarricense en
participar de unos juegos olímpicos y
que destacó por su desempeño deportivo
como por su poderoso mensaje
[Música]
más el boicot a israel en solidaridad
con el pueblo palestino ha sido noticia
en los juegos olímpicos' sin quedar
exento de críticas el destacado judoca
argelino fecha nuryn se negó a competir
contra su adversario israelí tójar a
wood bull y la federación internacional
de judo se desmarcó de esta decisión
considerando la opuesta a sus principios
y decidieron retirar la acreditación
alhaurina tras su llegada a argelia el
judoca declaró ante los medios que había
trabajado mucho para los juegos pero que
para él palestina es más importante y
cabe destacar que a argelia al contrario
que otros países de la liga árabe se
mantiene firme en su oposición a la
normalización de relaciones con el
estado sionista y aparte de norina en la
judoca sudanés mohamed abdel raúl
también se negó a competir contra el
mismo rival e israelí por su parte el
movimiento internacional de boicot
desinversiones y sanciones a israel
celebró estas decisiones que consideran
a ponen por delante la vida del pueblo
palestino y exigieron de nuevo que se
prohíba la participación de israel en
los juegos olímpicos' dicen al igual que
se hizo con sudáfrica para acabar con el
aparte
[Música]
haberse arrodillado para el libro de
eeuu en protesta a la brutalidad
policial y el racismo en el 2016 le
costó la carrera deportiva a colín
kaepernick jugador de fútbol americano
rompe en su momento pidió a la liga
nacional de fútbol despedir a cualquier
jugador que se arrodillara durante el
himno pero el gesto creció en todo el
mundo y llegó a los olímpicos las
jugadoras de fútbol de estados unidos
inglaterra suecia el chile entre otras
lo hicieron antes de empezar sus
partidos un gesto que anteriormente
hubiera sido sancionado pero que ante la
presión de los atletas del comité
olímpico internacional cambió estas
reglas antes de los olímpicos de tokio y
permitió que los atletas expresarán sus
posiciones políticas según la nueva
normatividad de estos gestos tiene que
cumplir sin embargo con los principios
fundamentales de las olimpiadas y no
atacar directamente a un país una
organización o un grupo de personas
[Música]